- Oh man.
Well welcome to the show.
But what happened?
What happened?
- Well, do you want the real
story? You want the cool story?
- I want the cool story.
Like you saved a baby from a shark.
- I did. I did, so here's the cool story.
We were out camping
with my kids and my wife
and a bear attacked us.
(laughing)
And I didn't know I had it in me,
I round house kicked the
bear, and he like paused.
I didn't physically hurt the bear,
but I think emotionally I hurt the bear,
started crying and, I
started crying cause I cry
and we were like, we talked it
out and everything was okay.
So I just, I learned
not to kick bears. Yeah.
- I love this story you've worked on.
I love that.
No, I hurt my foot once.
Mine was also not a cool story
and I had to make one up.
I just tripped over a pedal board on stage
and I had to wear it though,
like while performing
like on doing shows
and it's like annoying.
- Yeah.Yeah.
- [Kelly] And it's sweaty.
- It's sweaty.
I can't drive and my wife hates me for it.
It's cuz I can't get the kids places.
It's all on Her now.
- Oh, that's kind of nice though.
You're like, oh, the boot.
- [Guest] Don't tell her that.
- Yeah, I would do that too.